I'm very excited to share my personal
journey with the imposter syndrome at
the Grace Hopper conference for me this
has been a long and very personal
journey in managing these feelings of
insecurity that I felt over the years
imposter syndrome is a phenomenon that
was first identified in the late 1970s
by two female psychologists and it's
despite being accomplished being a
successful professional one still has
these feelings of I don't belong I'm not
really as smart as they think I am and
70% of professionals experience feelings
of being an impostor and it's not just
you know people think it's only women
for example but it is across the board
it's women men underrepresented minority
so marginalized groups or minority
groups tend to experience it more but if
you look at the research it suggests
that everybody does